so thanks I think that'll actually be a
pretty much shorter than the time
allotted I hope because what I aim for
is to give you a bird's eye view of the
options and of the questions and the
options you have when you think of using
a new your January model so first of all
what does that even mean generative is
the model that outputs a symbol a symbol
number generative probably not a word of
a modal choose one option out of ten
well hardly
one option out of a billion probably but
so I mean by generative models here I
will just mean models whose output spans
a pretty large universe so it's clear
there's a spectrum between things that
are generate everything they're not so
the first question if the first question
was or that you have to face when you
think of using a generative model is do
you actually need one for your problem
because all of these things they're
reasonable trickier and require a
reasonable time investment and so if you
can get away without using one you
should like if it's possible always go
for the stupid option for example if you
want a chatbot then quite likely just a
simple straight-up exclusive algorithm
that just selects one of 10 possible
templates and then equally with explicit
rules fills the blanks in the templates
will do just fine and in fact for some
of our for some of our natural language
generation tasks this has worked great
so in some cases if you can get away
without using complex things do and by
the way there of if you just want to
have a simple regression simple
classification task I could recommend
extreme gradient boosting that has
pretty consistently beating neural
models for simple classification
regression tasks in our practice and
there is nice Python library for this in
our library I think as well so that
should be the first particle if you
think if that's not good enough and you
still want something complex then what
you need to understand is the structure
of your problem
what are the important options the first
of the first one is what's the strategy
of the output space what are you trying
to produce and here the big distinction
is something continuous so basically
some kind of an n-dimensional array of
real numbers images audio that sort of
thing
and that's actually the easier and
that's actually the easier option the
other one which is in more interesting
is if your outpost pace is discrete and
discrete again can come in many shapes
the most common one perhaps is texts or
things that are in are things that form
a linear sequence but also for example a
series of button presses to win a
computer game is it can be looked at as
a generative task you produce a sequence
oh and that also is a linear sequence
but again this could not all discrete
problems a linear some of them are have
another structure the second most
frequent structure perhaps is a graph so
you have connections and possibly
different kinds of connections and
possibly inference on those so it's a
knowledge graph but in any case the
connections it's not just a line and so
the structure the output space is really
the important thing for the inputs it's
not as crucial for choosing your
approach as will see further in the
second big question is do you have an
objective function and that is really
perhaps well the second major
determinant of what you go for again
because the neural networks the neh
their native language is continuous
variables if you have a continuous
objective function your life is good the
other option is you have a discrete
value objective function where so for
example in natural language
understanding you have your model
produces an answer and your objective
function tells is this the right answer
is the wrong answer so then the function
is explicit you have black box that
gives you a valuation but it's discrete
and then
four and then finally a most frequent
and interesting case of course is when
you have just a set of examples either
just a set of for example images and you
want to produce more images like that
whatever that means or a set of
input-output pairs for example for for
machine translation so once you have
those two questions you need to you need
to decide based on this what model
structure to go for and here I
deliberately take a very high bird's-eye
view and will try to just so we didn't
get lost in the details and then we'll
be more than happy to drill into any of
the details once in the questions time
so basically in the generative models
there are three major optimization
patterns and of course none of it is
exclusive because all these areas have
been exploding so there are exceptions
to any general statement about any one
of those areas but I'm just trying to
cover you know if I had to solve a
problem in this domain what would be my
first port of call and the first one
perhaps the most powerful is encoder
decoder there you have again two flavors
so how does how doing Cori coders work
you take a bunch of real world inputs
with whatever structure they have and
you have an encoder which turns that
each input into either a vector or a
variable length sequence of vectors so
the big distinction here is it is it a
fixed dimensional encoded output or is
the output variable dimension so let's
look at fixed dimension which
essentially is equivalent to a vector
you want to use that if you want to
summarize your inputs in some way so in
particular case here is auto-encoders
where input and output should be the
same so then the decoder part is you
take that vector the exactly the vector
you've just encoded and you try to
produce the output you want from that
using the using the second network
called the decoder
and you train them to you train them
together so you have input-output pairs
for the auto encoder its input is the
same as the output and then encoder
transforms it in some kind of internal
vector decoder try to transform it back
and what is that good for well generally
whether it's Yves is that by squeezing
all the information in a complex initial
outputs through that little vector that
forces the networks to encode the defeat
is that matter for reconstructing the
input efficiently so then once you have
trained this kind of encoder decoder
pair then one thing people have done in
a bunch of domains last one was that I
heard was on astronomic object
classification was you can do clustering
in the in what is called latent space so
this space of the vector into which you
map into which think over maps your
inputs let's call the latent space and
in that latent space then you can do
clustering in a much nicer fashion
because by squeezing your complex input
into that tiny vector the network is
forced to encode the features of matter
so let's suppose and then you can do
clustering in that space the other nice
thing about this is that then you can
sample from that space so you don't once
once you have a latent space you don't
need to use the encoder you just take a
random vector from the latent space
apply the decoder and get back your
output of it so this is a nice pattern
however in some cases that one vector
proves to be too small or too too simple
a structure to squeeze all the
information into so then the second
equally popular version is an encoder
decoder where the encoded state is a
variable length sequence so you see this
a lot for example in natural language
translation where what you do an encoder
just takes a set of tokens which to
translate you come you convert your
input text into a series of tokens using
a favorite algorithms so the tokens
could be
words so they could be individual
characters they could be bite by pairing
coding whatever you like and then you
transform each token into one vector in
your encoded sequence and then the
decoder rather than taking the what the
single Layton space vector as an input
it takes the sequence and at each step
it applies weights using some kind of a
tension mechanism to get the average
weight attention way to average vector
for this decoder step and then repeats
so this way you can smuggle more
information through oh and which means
you get better translations for example
but at the same time it's less useful
for sampling from because how can you
sample from a variable length sequence
you could do it but it's just missing
the next one which has perhaps being
been the most famous one are the
generative adversarial networks ganz and
here you actually use almost the same
building blocks as for auto-encoders but
you put them together in a different way
so first you have a generator model
which usually can be exactly the same or
very much the same architecture as your
decoder which just takes Elliott vector
as an input and produces something in
your target space and then you have a
discriminator which tries to tell is
this particular output say this image
wasn't produced by the generator or was
it a real image and then you train the
two models in tandem so you train the
discriminator to distinguish and you
train the generator to fool the
discriminator now in in the world of
image generation so this has accused
spectacular successes but one big
practical downside is that these things
are notoriously hard to train so the
training can be because there is not
there's no such thing as a global
optimum because you're trying to the
generators are competing and so while
while the payer has potentially good
this is the the path that
is perhaps the most tricky however the
upside here is it all it needs from you
is a set of examples final one which not
everybody thinks of when they talk about
generating models
here's reinforcement learning and
basically and a broad definition of
reinforcement learning could be that you
could optimize an objective function
which is an outcome of many successive
decisions so the most famous one perhaps
is the alphago algorithm and then alpha
0 is successor which beat the world
champions in the game of go where the
where the target space is huge and only
at the beginning of a very long game do
you know whether you want or not and one
could one could and people have held
whole lecture courses about different
flavors of reinforcement learning but if
you just want to drive into it
a currently popular method which seems
to work quite well and it's not terribly
complex to implement it is proximal poly
septum ization the one thing you do need
for enforcement learning though is an
objective function so you need to have a
payoff at the end you know somehow
improvise the payer that makes sense so
this is in contrast to Ganz we just need
examples on the other hand the upside of
principled learning isn't he don't need
examples you can just as long as you
have a payoff you generally can produce
whatever it wants and all you need to
know is the score at the end so now we
have seen two bits we have seen the
shape of our problem and we have seen
the possible patterns the interesting
part is how you go from one to the other
and let's go through a couple through
several examples so the simplest one is
you have a continuous output space and
the continuous valued objective function
and this is the perhaps the ideal case
so if all you want to have is to
optimize your vector function then you
just create a network plug in the
objective function
run variant descent on the result and
you're happy maybe you want to produce
not one output that maximizes the
objective function but many then you
could introduce some randomization into
the process but in any case all these
networks have dropout so if you want to
produce a bunch of good examples you
just do inference with dropout turned on
and you have your decent outputs again
of course optimizations regretted this
and it's not without its pitfalls but
the same is true of all the methods here
so there I'm talking like really a
really big story now next case
continuous output space and it is create
objective function there really what you
want to do is to cheat a bit and to
train a proc and to train a proxy
objective function which is continuous
and here again the nice thing is you
don't need examples as long as you have
an objective function so so what you do
is you start a model with random weights
you produce a bunch of examples you
score them using a discreet objective
function and then you train a continuous
predictor of that objective function and
then you keep and then you have two
models but unlike in the Gann case you
don't this you don't try these models
all these options are not competing or
not necessarily when you train your
generator and then you train your
continuous objective function to
approximate the scores of the true
discrete haar right next space is
whatever discrete output space with an
objective function an example which I
have been playing quite a bit alluro in
my spare time lately he's molecule
optimization so generally when you work
in discrete spaces the trick people use
is to turn this into a continuous
problem and very placing a discrete
decision so this pre decision is you
take one of n options what you do
instead is you take a vector of
probabilities of choosing any one of
those options and the probabilities are
real valued so we're back into
continuous land
and so one and so one way you could do
this is you parameterize the output
space in a continuous fashion and here
we come back to our encoders so for
example if you have look one thing
people have have done for molecule for
molecular optimization is they feed
their molecule into an autoencoder which
trains to produce it and then you have a
Leighton space in the middle and then
the Leighton spaces continues so you can
sample from it it's not you cannot say
what is the point halfway between this
molecule and that molecule because the
space is creek but then when when you
have a mapper from point in the latent
space to a molecule your sample to
latent space and optimized all the
latest space um that is and that is very
nice especially because it's a simple in
general approach so again if in doubt
that's the first thing to try because
autoencoders are more stable to train
and then some of the other options but
the downside here is you assume the
collating space represents your object
space well which may or may not be true
so the other option you have here is to
go directly into your target space and
use very important learning approach so
any kind of discrete space construct
construction of any objects in discrete
space can generally be represented as a
series of more or less simple options
possible constant length was not a
variable length for example when you're
doing molecules then you can choose what
next item you want to attach or what
next structure you want to attach or if
you're playing a game which next button
do you press and then you can if you
want to work directly in that target
space then your important learning is
your friend
yes let's now we come into the stranger
world where we don't have an objective
function so we don't technically know
what we're trying to optimize but we
have examples and then so one perhaps
most famous example here is pictures and
I think everybody probably has seen the
celebrity face examples of no fiction a
fictional human or particular human
faces which look really nice and
realistic produced by Ganz so here again
the point is how do you if you don't
have an objective function how do you
how do you constrain the output of your
model to the space that is similar to
the examples how you define similar and
here the two options are 1st constrained
space from the inside so to speak so you
train on two encoder and then you hope
that anything that your decoder can
produce because our encode has been
trained this way he is now inside this
light in space and for images that
didn't work well enough so then the
other option is to constrain it from the
outside so your model can produce
anything but but at the end is must
satisfy basically you create a certain
objective function which is a
discriminator and then
then the other option is you don't have
an objective function but you have
examples of not just one thing about the
input-output pairs and that's a classic
encoder/decoder scenario right um so
this is this optimization style now that
she was how the construction model was
the architecture remote and surprisingly
enough those choices are almost
independent of the optimization stallion
shoes you don't always need an encoder
but you always do you always need a
decoder though sometimes you go to the
generator and you almost always need an
output transformation step so the
encoder architecture is actually the
simpler choice because so what's the
point what's the point of encoding the
point of encoding is to turn your
complicated real life input which can
have lots of discrete discrete features
some kind of a graph structure some kind
of pointers to other objects who knows
what to turn it into something in the
model of that neural networks can work
with so either basically a fixed fixed
length vector or a variable length
sequence of vectors and then and then
really if your inputs are continuous
audio video then real then they're
already such arrays so then you just
need to put the processing step after
that
um however often you have hybrid
structures so for so first of all if
individual elements so that continuous
for example their frames in a video or
they are or their other wave patterns
then you're fine
but then sometimes the sequence of for
example words or oh I think I think
words is most frequent it's a frequent
one then you embed them using either
embedding you train as part of your
model or you take canned ones for
example with word embeddings now often
you have hybrid things where each
element is continuous but then you have
a sequence of those which is a sequence
is discrete so if you have a sequence
put it through a narrow net if you have
if you have any kind of a continuous
thing put it through some kind of a
convolutional network and if you have a
graph like structure
you use a graph convolution network so
really it's usually if you look at a
particular case the structure of the
input drives the kind of embedding
issues the and then the other option
which is sometimes been useful is a
transformer architecture which is where
there was the lovely paper attention is
all you need so we are with our Nance
you take things one step at a time and
carry a state through the steps with the
transformer network instead each output
vector is composed of a weighted average
of all the input vectors driven by
attention and so here the the decision
is if you only want more or less local
information so for example RN ends they
don't really do great for information
propagation over more than a dozen steps
or so in a sequence so if your
information you want exchanging seq
elements is more or less local and RN n
is good or a graphic evolution network
is good if you want global information
propagation then use some kind of global
state or using transform architecture
the big downside of transform
architecture because everything is
feeling into everything one transformer
stage scales quadratically in the length
of your sequence
which might have might not be a problem
depending how long your sequences are
and the other rules of thumb is used
drop out liberally and if you use more
than two or three layers use residual
connections how know the decoder
architecture is where it gets more
interesting again for continuous outputs
it's again it's a world it's a world of
its own
but basically use a combination of apps
up sampling transpose convolutions and
convolutions for discrete outputs the
most common pattern is you do it in
steps so one discrete output is easy you
just produce a vector of probabilities
for each output but typically for
discrete outputs in the produces
sequence for example I wanted
participants of words the distance
Latian and then what you do is you do it
in steps he first produced the first
output in the sequence then you use then
then you use this
plus the encoder state to produce the
next output etc etc etc and then you can
either just select the highest
probability each time or you won't want
to look several steps ahead to look for
the highest cumulative probability which
is called beam search now here comes the
most fun part which is often
underestimated which is output
transformation because what your model
what your neural models can typically do
for you is produce a sequence of
probability vectors so for example if
you have and if you have something like
text wherever almost everything is
possible then that's enough because all
you have is reveal what is the
probability what is the highest
probability next word and you select one
word after another however in some cases
there are quite tight constraints on
what is valid for example if your model
should output a database query there are
quite tight syndics constraints on what
database queries should look like or if
your model is supposed to output a valid
molecule well you could train your model
to learn what valid molecules look like
but I'd much rather be spending the
model capacity
on training what good molecules look
like and make it unable to produce
invalid ones and that is where output
transformation comes in so basically the
point of a transformation is to make
life as easy as possible for your model
basically you know the ideal case to
ensure that any choice
that your model makes is a reasonable
result and then all the more has to do
is to optimize between the reasonable
results for the best ones because if you
don't do that that the model first needs
to learn what valid or is to learn to
avoid in value a terrible results and
that's a waste of training time model
capacity so one and there there is a
couple of tricks we can use one which
I'm very fond of is the use of grammars
so grammar you can I think of a grammar
as a series of templates for example if
you have a for example if you have a
database query you know it's adding
insert query or it's an update query and
then then maybe there is a group by and
so a grammar is a series of rules where
the first rule just starts from nothing
and starts a template with some blanks
to fill in any next grammar rule
substitutes a particular kind of blank
for another template and so on until
we're done until there are no blanks
left to fill and so whenever you have to
produce a highly structured input so if
database queries molecules or anything
where there are additional constraints
apart from the fact that is discrete
then the grammar is your friend and if
you're producing linear sequences then
what you want is a particular kind of
grammar called
context-free grammar it's probably the
easiest one um and that just the
context-free grammar just means that
when you're expanding a particular token
you don't care about how you got here
you only care about what token this is
and that doesn't work for graphs well
you can make it work for graphs but it's
painful and but there's a very similar
concept called the hyper graph replaced
in grammar which does work for graphs
and the final one which is perhaps the
most fun to use is to use an external
piece of software as the input
transformer so for example one talked at
last year's ICML was somebody who had
hooked up reinforcement learning program
to a graph drawing software and what
they were was what the reinforcement
learning model was doing is to give the
cord and there's a which particular
brushstroke and then the objective was
it gave you a pixel a pixelated picture
the Mona Lisa or whatever and the model
was outputting the brushstrokes which
were fed into a graphics editor which
then drew drew the result and try to
reproduce the picture and I think this
is this is something which is not done
very often but can be quite powerful
because there are so using an
experimental software as an output
transformer or another one is if your
model actually outputs a query as an
intermediate step and then if we could
put this query into some kind of an
internal engine and then the output of
the model is the result of the query and
the urge it and so when you're working
in discrete spaces there are many more
games we play like this so I could spend
another hour talking about know the
concepts in any one of those slides
probably but they can't rather stop now
and ask questions
[Applause]
[Music]
um sure
so in my purse in my case I've done a
lot of work in my spare time as a side
project on molecular optimization and
there what what I've started with was an
encoder decoder formulation but they're
very hard to train and and you have to
start from friend you have to start from
a big universe and I wasn't happy with
this so now what I've been doing is
reinforcement learning flavors for that
and because there and reported learning
flavors of molecules with hypergraph
grammars because with hyper grab
grammars you can guarantee validity of
your model so things like valances of
individual items can be guaranteed by
the grammar but then the thing is what
is the writer enforcement learning
algorithm to search over that space
another one which another one which is a
work in progress is opposed to text
engine for commands where the input is
just a character stream and which can be
very messy and error-prone and the
output is a series of grammar rules
which when evaluated produce a valid
command and this is this may which makes
it an easier problem than general
voice-to-text
because you don't you don't want to
produce an English sentence you want to
produce a a command from a fairly large
but still limited set of commands and
the nice thing about grammar is that
these things don't have to describe
limit describe call constant size spaces
because the grammars can be recursive
you know talking can you spent itself
etc so if for example if you have a
database query and you want to have an
arbitrary number of filter statements on
the end of constraints you can express
it in grammar so I think yeah these are
these are the two I've done worst case
well I think searching it is not
searching it in itself really though the
only the only two options you have well
the only three options you have is just
a sample of probabilities directly and
then hope something good comes out at
the end statistically or you do you just
choose the largest or then you choose a
beam search and I guess the well the
next were complicated option would be a
Monte Carlo tree search where you you
run a search sequence and then you
backtrack and then you feed back the
results of that particular search and
then we are the next search sequence
then at each step you know what your
previous run was like and so you so we
accumulate the results of all your runs
in a tree and the tree teaches or
something and then and then the next the
next more convoluted step which is for
how alpha zero worked which is at each
model step there ran a multi-car oath
research they get those results and then
the trade in neural network to reproduce
those results so there was a feedback
loop between neural network which gives
you the probabilities and the Monte
Carlo tree search which refines them but
this is really computationally hungry so
unless he can you know unless you have a
couple hundred CPUs and example hundred
GPU standing by
I wouldn't necessarily go there
[Music]
so so you want to produce images from
different classes
[Music]
three pages
well I do one way I can think of is to
use a semi supervised approach so you
first you take a large you take a
superclass which includes both Class A
and Class B but which is still not too
generic and you just train your model no
matter what to sample out of that and
then once so at least your model has
learned the the broader class in
developing class and then you and then
you refine the model with the specific
examples so that and that can then at
least the model has already learned the
broader class of which both because
members
so - so - so - steps can suggest so
first one is semi-supervised so first
you train the broader class and then you
refine the other one is targeted
enhancement of your class because or
just arbitrary laboring is expensive but
what you can do is then you have
techniques for estimating of the of
these the images labeling which one
would improve more than discrimination
ability the most and there are
techniques for doing that sort of thing
so if you have only three examples and
that's it then I don't have any other
ideas but if your problem is that there
are not that many labeled examples and
labeling is expensive then I would use
technique like this to choose which next
ones to label for the most efficiency
and people have done this for things
like cancers etc
so for example a grammar grammar would
be a grammar for database queries would
be from literal from than non-terminal
table name literal select and then a and
then a non-terminal field list and then
they'll be the rule number one rule
number two was the non-terminal table
name resolves to this table name one
terminal table name resolves to another
table name and so ever this set of rules
and then you know that if you have a
non-terminal called table name in your
sequence so far then the only thing you
could only really can apply to expand it
our rules
where the root is table name and
therefore and so to do this with your
modal you apply masking so where you
look at what you have like a you have a
helper function which is like an
environment anybody reported learning
where at each time when you're choosing
what is my next non-terminal I'm what is
my next non-terminal I'm trying to
expand and then depend depending on this
generate the mask so what would be the
valid expansion rules and then you
evaluate that rule you see what the
sequence looks like it looks like now
for example the table name is evaluated
so what is the next non-terminal to
expand next one terminal to expand is
which field I want to query for which
call them that one the query for then
for that you look at your next mortal
probability vector you know I'm looking
for a field name so you apply a mask
that on the rules whichever you ate to a
field name or which have a field name
and on terminal as or as a root apply
like and you iterate like this
the
so so no from the beginning you trained
your model rather than rather than
outputting for example set of characters
in database query what you trained your
model to output is the series of grammar
rules and so that's well that's it you
created training data set according you
so your model outputs a vector of
probabilities as they always do in the
screen cases but the vector describes
not the words you choose the character
to choose but what is the next rule to
evaluate and that's yeah and this works
and this works really great for anything
with structure no so that is like no
that's how our enforcement learning
works right so you have in reason we're
learning the whole point of
reinforcement learning is that your
reward is a black box so you can you can
replicate the back propagate through
your word so what you do is you run you
run your model once you produce some
random series of strokes and then so at
the end so the input so the model just
produces something and then the output
is a bitmap which is the result of those
strokes and then you have a reward
function which compares the bitmap just
pixel by pixel if you want to the
original model is a picture
know so that so for example II have 94
if you want to recreate it but yeah Mona
Lisa with three centimeter thick black
brush strokes as well as possible and so
the nice thing about reinforcement
learning is you create your own examples
so people sometimes people often
preacher and your most learning models
on known datasets because that's easier
but you don't have to you can start with
random and just well I think the trick
is T again this is an area of active
research there is no single answer but
one thing you could use is try to feel
it multiple or try to train on multiple
rewards is is one option the other
option is just pre training on example
datasets so it just starts out in the
same space and yeah I think I think
those are those are the biggest ones and
not another thing worth mentioning which
is also be a bit of a corner of
important learning but one nice thing
you can do is rather than trying to
optimize and predict the reward you're
going to get you can try and predict the
distribution of rewards that any given
action will get so at each step so at
each step rather than rather than just
evaluating the expected value of your
next step you try to predict the
distribution of rewards given actually
next steps and this give you more
information for choosing the next one
and this could lead to more of a saga
rhythms but yeah but generally you want
to have proximate rewards and the more
the better and train the more alone
together and then yeah I guess one one
thing you could even do is to supply
because again all these the networks you
use it's a sliding boundaries so what
you could do is you could actually input
your reward rather than just simulating
from nothing
you can start simulating from an input
vector and the input vector could recode
could record the reward that you're
currently optimizing and this way you
could train the same ways for everything
just forgiving it with different
protectors and but then hopefully
information would be shared across the
different rewards
[Music]
um well I think it's I would actually do
it more the other way around because the
point of the discriminator is that it
tries to it tries to exploit the
weaknesses of a specific generator so
you can't you cannot well I don't think
it's it it will be hard very hard to
train a useful general discriminator if
anything I would go the other way which
is you might first want to train a
generator using some simpler more robust
ways like a train generating is an
autoencoder and use this as a starting
point and then you plug in a
discriminator to refine it and I guess
the the other thing and again I'm not
throwing key words I'm explaining all
over the place but I'm just hoping that
you give those is again probably a half
an hour explanation but I hope that you
know if you're interested please come to
me afterwards I can just google them but
one nice thing one nice trick of
stabilizing Gans is of a certain
regularization and this basically means
if you if you if the space in which your
objects live has some kind of a net
national metric for example l2 distance
for images oh then by integrating that
mat you can integrate that metric into
how you regularize your models and that
makes it stuff more stable
all right well thank you very much and
please don't hesitate to email me so I'm
a geo are at a mosaics market you become
so if you want to bounce more ideas on
any of this please drop me a line
[Applause]